donald trump believes and is telling
people that he will be reinstated as
president
around august now when initially some
people reacted and said no no that's
fake news
the right-wing national review came out
and said not only does trump believe
that
there are multiple republican senators
who believe that david perdue believes
he'll be reinstated
martha mcsally believes she's going to
be reinstated
this is impossible there is no
reinstatement mechanism we have a
president
we have a line of succession the
president would be replaced by the vice
president if anything happens
then comes the speaker of the house for
now trump is neither i know earlier this
week we talked about
the possibility trump would run for
congress and then try to become speaker
of the house but for now trump is not
a former president is not part of the
line of succession
so one side of this is that donald trump
is starting to sort of lay the
groundwork
for a violent coup attempt that's one
side of it